c'est quoi la question mettez-moi la
question toujours derrière
pour cette ouverture alors moi je dis
déjà bravo Jean-Christophe Laurentin
donc les photos bon on va aller voir
dans un instant voilà c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas ça va oui c'est elle reste
très digne elle ne sert après la
fonction comme certes comme j'ai pu le
lire l'entendre ici et là bien sûr elle
est pas en drapé toute nue dans un
drapeau français comme j'ai pu le voir
aussi donc voilà elle reste elle ne
salit pas sa fonction elle
est dans des positions dans des tenues
étonnantes certes pour un ministre mais
ça reste tout à fait clean il y a un
piano
[Rires]
je suis désolé
alors c'est quoi la question oh c'est
quoi la question
oui c'est un super coup de com et que
cette polémique elle est presque sexiste
les photos elles sont pas choquantes
elles sont pas érotiques c'est des
photos qu'on aurait pu voir dans
d'autres magasins après et pourquoi je
dis sexiste parce que je me demande je
me pose la question si c'est un ministre
qui avait posé par exemple en une d'un
magazine comme têtu qui met en parfois
en scène des hommes torse nu dénudés et
ce qui aurait eu la même polémique je ne
pense pas ce qui choque c'est
l'association entre une ministre et un
magazine un peu sexy avec une réputation
un peu sulfureuse mais en soi il y a
rien de choquant et pour moi il dépasse
pas les limites en faisant ça et c'est
un super coup de com pour vous et pour
elle aussi donc bravo elle je suis
d'accord avec vous à tel point qu'on a
passé deux numéros en arrière à
interview de Jacques Attali
non mais si si elle parle au magazine
Elle elle parle à un lectorat qui est
déjà
convaincuité
défendre le droit des femmes à disposer
de leur corps c'est partout et tout le
temps en France les femmes sont libres
n'en déplaise au rétrograde et aux
hypocrites on parle de vous gilberté
[Rires]
ce qui est grave c'est la réaction du
Premier ministre ah ouais je suis
d'accord euh
qui vient la sermonner au prétexte elle
a pas le droit d'être photographié et
elle peut pas lire je profite son corps
pardonnez-moi et je mire de son corps
comme elle l'entend
donc
ça démontre quand même à quel point on
en est aujourd'hui
qu'on sera gardé et je me suis imaginé
Marlène Schiappa sous Mitterrand
imaginez qu'elle était ministre de
François Mitterrand mais on aurait ri on
aurait applaudi on aurait dit mais c'est
extra regardez comme on a régressé alors
elisabeth a dit ce n'était pas approprié
à fortiori dans la période actuelle de
crise sociale à la suite de la réforme
des retraites donc voilà et
Gérald Darmanin n'a pas hésité à prendre
la défense de Marlène Schiappa hier soir
sur cnews voilà donc c'était c'est force
qu'il a dit oui bien sûr regardez
à son style à son style je n'aurais pas
posé c'était inapproprié elle l'a dit
écoutez personne n'a vu personne moi je
vous dis que personne n'a vu cette
interview moi je l'ai pas lu cette
interview personne l'a vu donc d'abord
on commande des choses qu'on a pas vu
deuxièmement madame Chapa a fait savoir
qu'elle n'était pas pardon de rentrer
dans ce détail nu dans dans ce magazine
donc écoutez voilà écoutez moi je vais
vous dire je me ferais pas dire man
Chapa qui est une femme politique
courageuse qu'à son caractère qu'à son
style qui n'est pas le mien mais je le
respecte et vous l'avez dit en tous les
cas vous on vous retrouve dans une autre
revue très différente quand même c'est
la Revue des Deux Mondes je voudrais le
souligner parce que dans cette revue
alors c'est vrai que voilà il a défendu
c'est drôle d'ailleurs ce qu'il a déjà
Darmanin